[Music]
hello everyone
and welcome back to the road to 2000 as
always my name is caleb denby
and today i'm going to be taking you
through some of my
favorite games of chess they are
really exciting games because they
feature as the title says
pretty ridiculous material imbalances
to so to start off with we're gonna go
with uh you know a pretty conservative
material imbalance in our first game
compared to the other ones
to most people though it's the type of
imbalance that you know you would be uh
putting in your best games collection if
you were to win a game as wesley so does
and against dean loren and i should
preface this is one of my favorite games
of chess
as i said and so i do very much like
this game from wesley's point of view
uh and so don't expect any unbiased uh
commentary
over this one because i think wesley so
played like a genius and i want to show
it
to you guys so let's jump into it here
wesley starts with d4
obviously what else knight f6 c4
g6 knight c3 and then here uh ding loren
misses his last chance for equality in
the opening
here he could have played d5 going for
the grunfeld
instead he plays bishop g7 entering the
king's indian defense
which wesley effortlessly refutes with
e4
d6 knight f3 entering the classical
variations
castles bishop e2 e5
and white just castles in this position
we see knight c6
going for the mainline stuff d5 now
locks up the center for white and
attacks this knight on c6
the knight retreats to e7 and we see
knight e1
from wesley so i sort of jetted through
those opening moves pretty quickly there
white has a lot of different options
in the king's indian this is the
classical system uh as it's known
and dingleren just chose pretty much the
main line uh
here black has two moves basically one
move is to play
knight out to e8 and the other move is
to play
knight back to d7 why these two moves
well of course because ding loren's play
is going to come along this f file with
the move f5
f4 and after stuff like g5 and g4
digloran is looking to checkmate wesley
on the king's side
what does white do in response to this
well he has this massive central
advantage
black is clearly playing towards the
king's side in the direction that his
pawns points
and so wesley is going to be playing on
the queen
side of the board so while dingleren is
busy trying to checkmate wesley's king
wesley is going to be playing for moves
like c5 and activating his pieces on the
queen
side of the board now why is 98 even a
move when knight d7
obviously defends the c5 square well
white's ideas often involve opening up
this c file
putting some pressure on c7 and putting
some pressure on the d6 pawn
now what two squares does the knight on
e8 control that's right it controls c7
and d6 so 98 is an alternative here for
black but dingler n did choose the main
line
knight d7 in this case see wesley
develop very naturally with bishop e3
f5 the the really only move here for
black
f3 to support the center f4 and f3 also
had the nice little side effect of
giving our bishop
a little hidey hole to tuck away on g5
by black is the natural continuation of
the plan
h5 g4 g3 dingler n
like i said playing for checkmate and
now
wesley's idea in the opening is to go
rook c1 here
and after knight g6 by the way all still
theory i know we're pretty deep here but
the
the theory is pretty linear so there's
not too many alternatives on each move
for either side
uh and here wesley plays a pawn
sacrifice with the move c5
and this is his big opening idea
so why does c5 work well first and
foremost
black is going to be pretty unhappy
taking with the d-pawn here
this d-pawn's really important to lock
down white's pawn on d5
this spatial advantage can very quickly
turn into a past pawn and
you know much much worse for black if
this pawn has allowed some ability
and white can rip open the c file
anyways with moves like b4
consider taking this knight b5
c6 for example takes takes takes
and it's very clear that black's king
side attack is sort of going nowhere
and white's pieces are entering black's
position
and white is simply winning here so
can't take with the d pawn
so why not just capture with the knight
well that's exactly what dingler n does
uh now what is the point of wesley's
play why give up this pawn for free
well the follow up with b4 is actually
very very interesting
with b4 of course the knight is attacked
and black's play very much as i said
revolves around getting this g4 break so
how can you support the g4 break well
you could put this knight on f6
and this is sort of the ideal setup for
black and westley's play so far
has been to prevent black from getting
this ideal setup
the move knight d7 here would actually
lose the game
on the spot chat room do you see the
tactic to win the game for wesley so
here i'll give you just a few
few moments
to find the winning idea
and by the way hello to everyone in the
chat of course so happy to have you all
here
joining me manny by the way while you're
thinking about it asks where is the
bishop on ca going to
well very often this bishop just sits
right here and is ready to sacrifice for
a pawn
on h3 so while this bishop doesn't
usually develop out too far
it is a very very important piece for
black as we'll see and yeah the the
knight
or the chat room does have it the answer
of course is knight b5
and this pawn is now indefensible we
would love to play rook f7
but our knight is now in the way
why does this actually win the game well
knight f6 for example
knight c7 and uh oh this guy is trapped
rick b8 bishop a7 and
this is completely winning for white now
the knight
is coming to e6 the light squared bishop
is getting traded
and black's attack is not going to go
anywhere and white is up winning
material
so of course then this knight must step
to the awkward looking square
of a6 and it does so here the point now
is this knight is already defending c7
the seventh rank is open and black is
going to
keep this extra pawn the downside of
course
is that this knight is now very very far
away from getting to f6 and so this g4
idea
is a bit more difficult for black to
achieve so how do we follow up this pawn
sacrifice well wesley just develops his
pieces
knight out to d3 supporting the b4 pawn
and the c5 square
we see h5 and now knight b5 does come
anyways
uh while this pawn may be defended this
pawn is
not and now dingleren makes what i think
is
a pretty significant opening mistake
here
these days a lot of the time you'll see
the players with the black pieces
allowing white to capture this
a7 pawn making the material even
and allowing white some expansion ideas
on the queen side
but of course you know all things cost
time in chess and knight takes a7 costs
quite a bit
but this knight having to evacuate
itself at some point as well so spending
a few tempe
to take this pawn tempe that black can
use to advance his plans of playing g4
but diglern instead says you're not
taking my pawn
b6 and that guy's defended however of
course
b6 is making quite a few weaknesses
so i want to see if you guys can come up
with a good
reorganizing of wesley so's pieces to
take advantage
of black's play so far
i want to see a defensive idea and an
offensive idea
if you guys can figure it out
uh how to reorganize wesley sews pieces
i'll give you just a few more moments
and then we will talk about the ideas
um okay while the chat room catches up
with us i am going to reveal some of the
answers
okay the chat actually says a4 and this
is exactly
the wrong idea in my opinion so
first the defensive idea of course we
know black's plan black's plan is to
play g4
in some manner or another and thanks to
this knight being on a6
white can do a very very effective job
of preventing
g4 from being played using an idea that
shows up
in some other lines of the king's indian
defense of course the move i'm talking
about here
is the slightly strange looking bishop
e1
this is a fantastic way to reorganize
the white pieces
uh starting with bishop e1 of course b6
stunts this bishop on this diagonal so
why keep it there
anymore why not move it to a more useful
square from e1 this bishop is defending
the b4 pawn and on top of that after
black's next move of rook f7
preparing to bring the rook into the
game we see first bishop d2
now this bishop is contesting black's
control
over this diagonal sometimes you would
have seen black try and develop the
bishop out through h6
no more because white is in control and
we also see this knight landing on f2
directly prohibiting black from
expanding with the move g4 this is the
great
defensive remaneuvering by wesley so in
this game
and then after the move queen e8s it's
time for some offensive
maneuvering so we've taken advantage of
b6
wasting some time for black to
reorganize our pieces defensively
get this bishop back to a more useful
square now how do we
take more advantage of b6 highlighting
the weaknesses
it creates what do you think chat
how can we take advantage of the
weakness created
by b6
and then actually the chat is coming up
with some interesting ideas which i
think they're interesting because
they're not quite right but they're
definitely
worth talking about definitely worth
talking about
yeah knight a3 is actually a pretty
interesting idea
so net a3 i think is just going to be a
bit too
slow here um
sure you can put your bishop on b5 you
can put this guy
on c6 maybe but maybe black will even
play a defensive move like bishop b7
it seems sort of paradoxical to defend
on the queen side like this when you
need the bishop to help attack
but the major pieces are going to come
to the king side
for black and with this knight on a3 i'm
just really not sure
how you make all that much progress keep
in mind by the way
there is an eventual plan right there is
an eventual plan
that we'll see coming from uh from ding
loren
so knight a3 is interesting the way i
was thinking of to take advantage of the
light squares is the way that gill
wolf in the chat actually came up with
the reason i was thinking a4 is a
bad move for white is because we would
much rather occupy this a file
with our pieces we can apply a ton of
pressure to this knight immediately
by placing this queen on a4 taking
advantage of the weakened light squares
of b6 while the c6 square is important i
think right now
taking advantage of the awkward
placement of black's pieces
should come first
gill actually said it threatens knight
takes d6 which isn't immediately true
because these queens would be in contact
but after bishop d8 we actually see the
second part of wesley's genius
remaneuvering here
which is queen a3 so he simply sticks
this queen
on the very strange looking a3 square
but the queen makes a ton of sense here
it is pressuring the knight on a6
this now is in fact an actual threat and
wesley
is just pressuring things on the queen
side
with all that in mind dingleren decided
it was go
time and plays the move g4 if ding
doesn't play g4 now he may never get a
chance to
for example some improving move like
knight h4 might be met with h3 when all
of a sudden
this idea of playing g4 is sort of
in a bygone era right you're always
going to be sacrificing a pawn now
if you play the move g4 note also this
strange looking queen on
a3 is actually a good defensive piece as
well
this idea of the third ranked defense
often shows up in the king's indian
and so queen on a3 just a fantastic
piece
anyways now we're never for ding loren
he decides this is the time to play the
move g4
white captures on g4 takes on g4 and
then we see
wesley go knight c3 what's the idea
the idea is that we are attacking this
knight two times
and it is only defended once tough to
stop
for uh digloren and here ding finds
himself
at a crossroads he could play the move
knight b
eights but if he plays this move then
white can in fact capture on g4
no he couldn't do that before because
the knight on b5 was hanging
and after white captures on g4 if black
is unable to rip open files
on the king's side black is going to be
very very much
worse off in this case and so ding shows
the active idea the
you know the idea in the spirit of the
king's indian defense and sacrifices his
knight on b4
uh now wesley sort of has no choice he
has to take this guy back
and black can rip things open with the
move
f3 but what is wesley's idea
how do you keep your king safe after
this terrifying move
f3 lands on the board
how do you keep your king safe now was
this a classical match absolutely
it was it was oh it's on the screen
ben's on it tonight it was from the
bilbao masters tournament in 2015.
so the chat is saying some things like
put an alkyne's gun
on the c file these ideas in the king's
indian are are very much
not going to get you a ton of success
the reason being
king's indian is in at its core a race
black races to checkmate white white
races to break through on the queen side
and whoever gets there first is usually
going to be the victor in these cases so
these slow ideas like you know rerouting
all the pieces here
they are just not really what the doctor
ordered for the king's indian
so the first step of the plan the chat
room does have you
gain time with the bishop by going
bishop b5
the queen moves out to e7 or f8 doesn't
really matter
and from here we can play g3 to keep
this pawn
right there on f3 keep it out of our
face
or keep the major pieces out of our face
and leaving this pawn on g4 as well
but there is a really critical second
part to this plan that we'll see a
little bit later on
that helps defend the white king rook h7
is played
and now wesley does start to invade with
the major piece
meaning the queen here we see queen c4
and dingleren's idea now is very simple
he says
okay you shut down my f file but look
out
there's a weak h2 pawn and so it's
really really important
that wesley had this idea in mind before
going g3 what idea is that well let's
take a look
ricciate is the next move for ding loren
he's saying
yeah one two three four you have four
moves to do something on the queen side
or else you're in checkmate buddy so
let's see what happened
uh queen c6 is wesley so's idea
and now queen h7 lands on the board in
chat room what do you do
you're checkmated your checkmated dude
he put
his pieces on the h file and now he's
gonna checkmate you
what are you gonna do you're westley so
you know you were so confident you
sacrificed this pawn on the queen side
you re-maneuvered your pieces
to be more defensive and then ding just
sacks the night on you and what you're
just you're checkmated now
it's all over is it true
so aryan in the chat has the right idea
there is an incredible defensive idea
that shows up in this game
which is to close the h file how do we
possibly close the h file if we do
something like h4
the very natural move well guess what
you know this is gonna get captured by a
bishop at some moment maybe black should
save the rook first
but then bishop takes h4 is unstoppable
but the move
h3 is the killer idea to completely shut
down black's attack
in one very very easy move
what's the point the point is if you
take this guy
well first of all you might be hanging a
rook second of all king h2
we do not take back on h3 we leave this
pawn here
and now both of black's pawns are
actually playing on our
team uh the only square left for black
to break through
is on g3 and that's just not going to
happen any time soon rook g1
is playable the king already defends
this pawn
and uh white would be completely safe uh
in the game
dingleran first saves this rook
we see the move knight c to d1
unleashing more firepower on the c file
and now we see the move a6
by ding loren and it's moment of truth
time
all right why is this game in this
lecture
alright i'm sure you've had lot more
than enough time
looking at this game you know wondering
when or when
are we going to see a ridiculous
material imbalance well
wait no longer now is your time
now is your time what is the winning
idea here
for wesley so
so i would be surprised if somebody in
the chat could off the cuff just give me
the full line here
uh but manny does have the correct first
move of course you
you know give check to the black king
but what is the point king
g7 all of these squares are
defended what is this queen doing here
you know uh there's nowhere to go but
back to c6 right
wrong free bishop wesley so sacrifices
his
queen queen takes d8 we see rook takes
d8
rook takes c7 with a skewer on the black
king but wait a minute this can be
blocked by bishop d7
but wesley says yeah you know i saw it
all coming
rook takes d7 rook takes d7 bishop takes
d7
uh and what is this we have one knight
and two bishops
in exchange for a queen and after g
takes h3
two pawns okay is that ridiculous enough
for the lecture
you tell me remember this is the this is
the normal looking game of the lecture
we started off
simple okay so if you can't handle three
pieces for two pawns and a queen
then you know get get ready brace
yourself for what's coming next
all right so why is this so good for
wesley
well as some people in the chat are
saying black lost a lot of his firepower
in these exchanges a rook came off the
board both
bishops came off the board and it's
going to be very difficult
to checkmate this white king now you
simply can't really break through
there's no way to attack g3 and as we
discussed that's really the only square
left
for black to break through um it's also
going to be easily defended
with the king on h2 so yeah king h2 of
course should be the move here
technically you can capture this pawn
but why would you that pawn's on your
team
just king h2 you can take this guy
whenever you want and you definitely
don't want to for the moment because
waiting on the other side of that pawn
is you know a veritable army
so look out there rook b7
was ding lorenz try wesley so calmly and
simply defends his bishop
we see the move knight f8 trying to take
the bishop again wesley so says okay
i'll move one more time bishop f5
the queen comes to age five and now how
would you guys
like to organize your pieces here what
is going on
in this game um basically what i'm
asking is
sure you know you did great if your name
is wesley so
you got these three pieces for the queen
usually that's
pretty good you know the the three
pieces together if they can coordinate
are better than the queen in many cases
but what is the actual plan
what does wesley want to do in this
position what can wesley try to do
in this position should he go you know
after some pawns you know maybe b6 maybe
d6 maybe start collecting these guys
what is
what's the plan for wesley how do you
actually use these pieces
what do you think chad
what do you think so the answer might
not be what you expect
wesley so in this case said yeah you
know i've had enough
of this playing on the queen side
business it's it's time for me to check
my opponent okay that's wesley's plan
here he activates his pieces
he says yeah good job pushing all those
pawns in front of your king
now that i have uh in a sense two
extra pieces to play with uh compared to
the one queen
which by the way is looking pretty
useless over on the king's side here
i am going to now play for checkmate
with these minor pieces he starts with
knight g4
and look out man look out this bishop's
coming with with a force
knight d7 was dingleren's try
and supposedly this is like you know the
quote-unquote losing move black is
already doing pretty badly
but the engine likes this move rook f7
with the idea
uh eventually
of getting white to trade things off
here
and at the end of the day um
white should be able to end up with a
material
edge i believe with something like this
and while this isn't too far off
from what happened in the game
apparently this is a better version
why is it a better version that's that's
a question for the
silicon mines
i don't really get it anyways what ding
loren played is knight of knight d7 and
i think this is a very human move you
try to get the knight to f6 you try to
battle back against these white pieces
and you know rook f7 these ideas while
they may work in engine land i think
over the board uh practically
in human games these ideas don't really
have too much of a place just wanted to
throw that out there
if you're wondering what led to total
destruction
uh instead of just a worse position it
was this move97
bishop h6 now appears on the board what
else attack the
attack the black king ding loren chooses
the h8 square for his king
we see knight d to e3 uh wesley
activating
his fourth and final minor piece
rook c7 for ding loren now look out
buddy don't go
don't go too crazy you might get
attacked
and now wesley plays this move bishop
takes d7 and so like i said
pretty similar uh to what happened in
the game turns out wesley could have
actually gone for a bit more with this
strange looking move
bishop e6 this knight does a great job
defending the white king
really nothing to fear on that front and
the point now
is that something like knight f6 to
trade knights
is going to run into rook takes f3 and
then
if you're not careful play something
like rook g7 for example
98 and you are actually just getting a
little bit checkmated here
with this king running out of squares
quite quite
quickly and in this case i think the
best black can do is somehow give up
the rook for one of these knights and
then just very clearly be losing
in the game though wesley saw a good
line and went for it bishop takes d7
rook takes rook takes f3 rook f7 now
trades off pieces
and how should westley continue not with
rook
takes f7 but of course the killer idea
by wesley now
is rook f5 allowing black
to capture this rook but after e takes
f5
giving himself a past pawn and from here
on out
with total coordination with the white
pieces wesley so just very very easily
converts this end game into a full point
queen f7 is what digler wren tried
pretty sensible move i might say
i might say myself you know getting in
front of the pawn pressuring the pawn
not trying to let it advance
but now uh chat room how do you actually
put him away
how do you put ding loren out of this
game how do you
actually turn this into a point
knight f6 was a fork well you got to be
careful with some of these things right
if you go
knight f6 willy-nilly you might get
checked got to be careful sometimes
you got to be careful
yeah here okay well i guess you don't
get checked but you might be losing this
and and this anyways how do you turn
this into a full point
how to win
so i will go ahead and reveal the answer
the trick here is understanding
the advantage three pieces have over the
queen
the advantage is they can sort of do
different
jobs while still supporting each other
so
uh while they can all do different jobs
control different squares
one another huge advantage that they
have over the queen is that whenever
they are threatening to trade one of the
minor pieces for the queen obviously
black has to decline and run away even
offering to trade two minor pieces for
the queen is fine
for white so if a piece is ever defended
and attacking the queen
then black absolutely has to run away so
using this idea
it's actually very easy to win this
position by
taking over these squares just simply
one at a time
so white's first move is bishop g5 why
bishop g5
well after black's next move it's
apparent we want the h6 square for our
knight
and all of a sudden things are starting
to become very very
clear queen f8 was dingleren's choice
now
f6 king h7 played
and now the second knight joins the
party knight e to f5
king g6 looks like it's attacking all of
white's remaining pieces
but bishop h4 is perfectly fine now for
wesley
e4 and f7 once again
the piece is taking over the f file one
square at a time
what's next after e3 of course it's
bishop e7
and the final square on the f file has
fallen
to white's control
now ding loren was sort of running out
of ideas i suspect if you try to take
this by the way
and go e2 i think this
is the best you can actually do but
wesley believe it or not
is prepared to stop this pawn so who saw
the tactic
to stop this pawn well okay i'm sorry
there's knight h4 knight f3 but if you
want to be cool you can go
knight e5 check as well and the point is
bishop b4
to stop this guy up a piece for wesley
so
so what dingleran tried instead was the
immediate e2
but now after knight h4 check the king
has to leave
the attack of this guy if king takes h6
by the way
this gets taken with check followed by
knight f3
so king h7 was the choice now we see
bishop takes that fate
and black gets a second queen on the
board but it just
does not matter uh one more accurate
move
by wesley so and the game is over bishop
takes d6
allowing white to queen on the next move
it's also supporting this pawn
and white is completely crushing now
queen f2 check
was played but with the knight around
the king there is
no chance for perpetual king g4 queen c4
check we see bishop f4 and ding
gave a couple more checks we saw knight
f3 and here dean loren
resigned rather than face down queen e7
knight g5 check king takes h6 knight h6
check
and queens so what a game by wesley so
sacking the queen for three pieces and
then
maneuvering around that black king and
coming to a full point
so what's better than sacking a queen
for three pieces well of course it's
sacking a queen
for two pieces which brings me to the
next game i wanted to show you guys
we've got a lot to cover tonight so no
time for a break
i am going to show you a fantastic game
by
um historical famous player
nejmedinov close enough against
chernikov
and this was played a long long time ago
i think in the 1970s i don't remember
the exact year
but let's just jump into it this game
starts with e4 a bit of a
change of pace from the game we just saw
and we very quickly
go into some lines of
the dragon with g6 fun stuff okay we see
knight c3
uh bishop g7 just normal accelerated
dragon stuff here bishop e3 played in
this game
knight f6 bishop c4 by white taking
control over the critical d5 square
black castles we see bishop b3 now for
white getting this bishop on the
defended square
away from ideas of d5 as well and black
chose a bit of a sideline in this
case so
white setup involves this nice bishop
here on e3
what a good looking bishop supporting
our center at pressuring the king's side
wouldn't it be nice if this bishop had
to move
this is black's thinking and so we see
the move knight g4
obviously this move has a downside the
downside is
this knight is hanging for free and
white captures it in this scan
obviously this is not a blunder of a
piece because by capturing on g4
white undefends this knight on d4 so
black is going to regain this piece
immediately
with knight takes d4 and then we see uh
nejmedinov go for queen h4 here with
some ideas
of pressuring black's king's side early
early on
uh queen a5 was black's choice in the
game and i don't think this is played so
often anymore
perhaps looking for some lateral defense
as well of course
uh looking for the pressure on the dark
squares that comes with the dragon right
pressuring this net on c3
uh nizmetanov didn't flinch he just
castles
uh king's side and after bishop f6 i
would like you to find
some candidate moves here for white
what do you think chat what should white
play in this position
all right ariane i think may have seen
this game before of course
the move here is queen takes f6
what an absolute stunner of a move
the point being after the move e takes
f6
you've moved upon to g6 you no longer
have a pawn on e7
you've lost your dark squared bishop
guess what
there's you don't have any more knights
as well
you're quite simply out of pieces to
defend dark squares around the king
they're
literally no more pieces that can defend
those squares besides for the rooks and
the queen
and the rooks are quite far away from
accessing any of those dark squares
so nezhmetanov gives up this queen with
the understanding
that black's defenders around us king
are
are completely absent just completely
completely absent
chernikov throws in an accurate move
here by the way if the immediate e takes
f6 we would see bishop takes d4
and white's play is coming even even
faster with knight d5 knight takes f6
coming
but a good inner meso for black is 92
check the point now being we distract
this knight from the d5 square we don't
allow the bishop to come to d4 with
tempo
and now black can recapture the center
meso is so good
that we actually see nezhmetanov play
knight back to c3
right you know playing slowly not often
what you see
after you've sacrificed a queen but it's
not that white is playing
slowly here it's that his pieces very
clearly have squares that they want to
be on
so why shouldn't he take the time to put
them there and that's exactly what's
going on here
in the game chernikov plays the move
rook e8
pressuring white's center and now of
course
knight d5 by white is the natural
follow-up indirectly defending this pawn
thanks to some tactics and now rookie
six
comes on the board for chernikov
chernikov well aware
of the situation facing his king he
understands that he's run
out of minor pieces to defend his dark
squares and so he's
very very ready very willing to give up
a rook to get
some semblance of control over these
dark squares once again
the natural continuation for nejmedinov
is bishop d4
just piling piling piling up on the f6
square
and here chernokov goes for king g7 just
defending
this guy with all of his might so chat
now you've activated the knight you've
activated the bishop these were the easy
pieces right we knew exactly where they
went
what's next for white how do you
increase the pressure
right i gave this big long speech about
how black was out of defenders for the
dark squares around his king
but now he's using his king to defend
this pawn and he's using a rook to
defend this pawn so we just
what we don't have enough to break
through we we throw in the towel we give
up
or or what what is next for nejmar
[Music]
enough
so i'm seeing a couple ideas in the
chats
be sure to give me some specifics don't
just say
you know a general piece or general idea
so there are two ideas being thrown
around and one of those is
f4 f5 and while f4 f5 is you know like
a common attacking sort of idea i
do not think it makes uh the most sense
in this case right
i think it's like fine you know this is
a fine idea to try and displace this
rook perhaps
but there's something better that white
can be doing with this time
instead of removing this defender we can
just add another attacker and that is
the idea of the rook lift
that other people in the chat are
mentioning rook 8's d1
d6 played by black desperately trying to
get this bishop into the game
and now the very simple rook d3 bishop
d7
rook f3 it's not very often that you can
spend
three full tempe to add an attacker to a
pawn
but that's exactly what happens in this
case and that goes to show you the power
of this position
right black has lost every dark square
defender around his king
besides for this rook and the king
itself and so
uh white just simply brings in the rook
and what can black do
black can't do anything right it's just
impossible to defend these dark squares
which is why this queen sacrifice
even for two pieces is so powerful in
this case
bishop b5 was black's tri uh
and now najmaranov throws in a little
bishop c3
trying to avoid any ideas of back rank
mate potentially in the future
uh but i'm not so sure it was the the
greatest it does force this queen back
to d8
to a better defensive square and now we
see
finally nejmedinov breaks through on f6
with the point being you cannot really
return the queen in this case
if you do so
um for example takes here means root d6
so king takes f6 or d1
uh count em white is up
upon easy advantage and in fact white is
sort of just completely winning in this
position
because black's pawn structure is also a
bit fractured so
don't even think about returning um
that uh the queen and by the way white
doesn't even have to accept it
this rook is in a forever pin and will
not be escaping any time soon
so the point is don't even think about
playing the move rick takes f6
um instead in the game bishop e2
was the very strange idea that uh
chernikov tries
the point being he's trying to trade one
of these light squared pieces in
exchange for this rook which of course
is attacking the dark squares
but now uh neshmetanov is completely
completely winning so see if you guys at
home can find the winning tactic
the knockout punch here for nejmedanov
what is the winning tactic guys let's
see what you
can come up with what is there
it's not the simplest but it is pretty
good
knight g4 is being suggested i don't
know
exactly how i feel about that can i
run this way right if you take my rook
i'll take your rook
king f8 in response to nhg4 guys maybe
king f8
knight h5 king f8 again king of fade
again
are you noticing a common problem here
are you noticing the theme
the theme is black has an escape route
right
so why not take it away from him
and yeah you guys have the right idea
knight takes h7
and now king f8 is highly highly illegal
so what's the idea well the idea is if
you take this guy
rick takes c6 king h6 and just the
simple
bishop takes e6 is going to be good
enough you can even throw in this check
as well
if you would like well actually if you
go here this is just
checkmate so you would have to go g5
and then stuff like taking this bishop
takes f1 is sort of a meager reply
when met with bishop f5 and check mating
ideas
queen h8 guess what there's bishop c3
queen g8 i guess is a better try but you
get checked
and lose the lady and of course now two
bishops against stroke very very good
uh along with the multitude of pawns
that white now has so the point is
knight takes h7 this guy
can't be captured rook takes f7 bishop
takes e6 just far
too powerful note that the difference is
here black isn't taking an f1 he's
taking on
f3 and that is the key difference right
we don't really care about the rook on
f1 but we care very much about this rook
and f3 the rook and f1 isn't playing
the rook on f3 is a very important
attacker so
the knight takes h7 the point being you
can't take this guy because we saved the
important rook
who cares about this rook and f1 and win
the game
um trinikov found the best move which
was to try to come back to g8s
and then nejmadanov comes in with the
move rook
h3 potentially knight f6 check first was
a bit better
for reasons involving just the straight
tactical idea here
because here chernikov actually finds a
very good defensive
resource that would not exist had
uh metal knob played out of six check
first so with knight f6 check first
you can't really step onto g7
or uh
h8 because knight d7 check is going to
be the idea
and the point now is that rook h3 is
coming a tempo faster
because the net on h7 is not in the way
and if you come to f 8 then once again
rook h3 is going to be strong if king g7
there's knight d5
check if king d7 there's rook e1
and this position is sort of just
crushing for nejmedinov
um obviously the game is going to
continue a few more moves but like rick
h7
this is tough to stop it's just very
very good
but in the game nejmedinov plays rook h3
first and
chernikov finds the best defensive try
he can with rook e5 uh just
blocking this diagonal at all costs
desperately trying to regain some dark
squares
but it's not enough f4 comes on the
board and now
black's best try was to go rook h5 when
white would have to settle
for this something like check
here takes and bla or white is doing
very very well in this position but it's
still a game
to be sure instead chernakov tried
bishop takes f1
king takes f1 is the simple move now and
then
rook c8 was his try um
bishop d4 is the mean move by nejmedinov
not even allowing black to sack this
rook for the dark squared bishop this is
why it's most valuable piece on the
board
no way is he giving it up b5 played
uh now nejmedanov isn't even happy with
taking this guy
when the bishop would force to believe
would be forced
to leave this diagonal we instead see
knight g5
rook c7 now trying to defend some
squares desperately
and azmanov unleashes a flurry of
tactics bishop takes f7
rook takes f7 rick h8 check takes
knight takes f7 knight takes d8
and in a few short moves uh black
resigned
realizing this end game was hopeless
so very impressive game by nejmedinov a
player that you're going to want to be
aware of
for sure by the way it was from 1962 as
i'm seeing on the screen now
um not the 1970s had my timelines a bit
messed up
and she mounted off a bit older than i
realized the more you know
um and yeah this is just a very very
impressive game uh
obviously this is an opening idea that
is now pretty well known and the
sicilian i believe you don't see it come
up too often
but this is an idea you know that exists
and the point being
these dark squares around the black king
are just so so
important and white in some cases can
even give up the most valuable piece on
the board for it
okay with that i want to move
right along to the next game and this is
the game
that actually gave me the idea for this
lecture
now the players in this next game aren't
quite as strong as world famous as the
players in the first two
but they are very strong players uh the
players in the next one
are actually gregory operon a grand
master currently attending
uh mizzou in in missouri here
and his opponent was cameron wheeler and
the setting of this game
was the u.s collegiate rapid
championships which just took place last
weekend
and after seeing this game i i knew i
had to talk about crazy material
imbalances
because this might be the single most
ridiculous material imbalance i have
ever seen in my life so let's jump into
it
um yeah of course this was a 10-minute
game with a five-second increment played
this last weekend of course being a
rapid championship
and yeah like i said players not quite
as world famous as the first
two games but they definitely make up
for it with the position
they managed to achieve so let's jump
into it here we see
f4 by gregory opran going for the bird
black chooses this line with g6 which i
think is a very respectable try
against the bird the point being very
very often white wants to take over
these dark squares in the center and
open up this diagonal for his bishop
and black says fine you played one f4
i'm getting to the diagonal first good
luck with that buddy
so knight f3 bishop g7 now g3
open sort of switches plans from the
traditional bird idea of doing this
c6 now by cameron is stunting the light
squared bishop in advance
see bishop g2 queen b6 now is an
interesting opening idea
for cameron wheeler oops not b3 the
point is he's pressuring
this b2 pawn with two pieces now so we
see the move
knight c3 by gregorioprin just removing
this pressure by sticking a knight in
the way
d5 by cameron we see d3 now
for gregory opran preparing to make sort
of this king's indian attack
type pawn structure with support from
the c
pawn up through the h-pawn resulting in
these two pawns on the fourth rank
we see knight f6 and now e4 sort of
structure complete
for open castles for
black and now i'd like before we get
into the crazy stuff
where you know there's material flying
everywhere i want to talk to you guys
about this
position a little bit and about how to
evaluate a position like this
um as far as my database goes this
position had never been seen before so
they were definitely
probably out definitely probably i'm
willing to guess
that they were out of their preparation
here if they have any preparation on the
bird to be honest
not many people have too much depth
against the bird
but how do you decide what to do in this
position how do you figure out what's
going on
how do you figure out who should be
better in some weird
type of position that you're not totally
familiar with right a weird queen on b6
a weird bishop on g7
weird structure very very strange
structure for white
how do you figure out figure out what to
do here
yeah chess king says no one grabbing the
center they they got there eventually
you know sometimes these grandmasters
it takes them all to catch on that the
center is important
so how do you assess this position
um okay maybe the question is a bit too
vague to get a specific answer
basically i think you can arrive at some
very good moves
for white in this position by relating
it
to positions that might be a little bit
more familiar or a little bit more
theoretical or classical right the first
thing i'm looking at
is this pawn structure c6 d5 with this
bishop sitting back here
on c8 what does this remind me of well
of course i am a karo khan player myself
so i'm thinking okay how does this look
compared to some kerala cons i know well
if e5 we would of course get you know
some tour
some sort of classical type variation of
the carol khan
but it would be one where white already
has this pawn on f4
can play d4 very very quickly and my
bishop
actually hasn't yet been developed and
so thinking about that i would be very
very tempted to try this move e5 here
for white and then thinking a bit
further you say where does this knight
go okay maybe this knight goes to
g4 can come back to f5 at a later date
so this knight isn't such a big deal
but let's say e5 knight g4 d4
what's going on here for white what's
going on here
for black well first and foremost this
bishop is sort of an awful piece
i'm not so worried about knight h6 to f5
because i can always go
h3 and even g4 to try and take over
those squares
and most importantly c5 is going to be
difficult to achieve for black and
because of that single reason
i would say white is doing very very
well out of the opening here
you can relate it back to things that
you're more familiar with in my case
familiar with the kero khan and e5 d4
is going to be a very good version of
the cairo
for white because this key break of c5
that i know from those structures is
going to be difficult to achieve so
that's how i like to sort of get a get
my bearings for where i am
i think about what moves are important
in positions similar to this
and then figure out you know the details
the specifics so let's see the
specifics here we do see e5 by grigori
knight g4
d4 and cameron now tries to go h5 to
cement this knight on the g4 square
make sure he doesn't get hit by an early
h3
g4 we do see h3 by gregory kicking this
knight away
and now castles knight a6
rook b1 is a slightly strange move by
grigori but perfectly fine here
note c5 right now is still difficult to
get due to the weakness on
d5 which is why we see first knight f5
king h2
with a point that this pawn is weak and
then knight c7 by black this is why we
saw this weird little maneuver
black understands he needs to defend
this d-pawn before pushing c5
now a very very instructive idea by
gregory opran
cements white's advantage and i think he
saw this coming
from quite a ways away so white to move
and get sort of a positional lock
in the position i'll give you just a
moment and then i'm going to tell you so
if you want to think about it more
pause here of course the positional lock
in this position
arrives after the move knight a4 hitting
the queen
and locking down the c5 square queen a5
is cameron's tri c3 now controls the d4
pawn and defends the knight
and after knight e6 the follow-through
of this idea
is of course the move b4 white
completely takes over the c5 square
and black is just getting crushed in
this position to be totally honest with
you
this is tough queen c7
is what cameron played rook f2 is the
slightly slow move by gregory opran
maybe playing a bit faster would be
interesting here
and now a5 by cameron wheeler
and gregory actually doesn't respond
quite accurately to this it turns out
best for him would have been to take
this guy put this knight on b6
take this guy and double double
and now eventually
playing g4 on the king's side breaking
through on the queen
side with uh pressure on b7 gregory
opran would have a very good position
there are even
some ideas of pushing c4 and activating
this guy so just
crossing position here for gigory
instead he chose
b5 which sort of runs into cb5
rook b5 and bishop d7 when unfortunately
things are starting to get a little bit
awkward now
for white for example if you bring this
rook back to b1
guess what i'll take this i'll take this
and
all of a sudden maybe i'd rather be
black winning a pawn in this position
with pressure on d4 so b5 allowing black
some tactical ideas here to break free
and we see our first material imbalance
of the game
so white to move and find
an interesting idea i guess is how i'm
going to phrase this
uh and once again we are running a bit
short on time so
i am just going to reveal the answer so
if you want to think about it see if you
can find an interesting idea for
yourself go ahead and pause here
i think i just showed an arrow for like
a quarter of a second but that's fine
rook takes d5 is the move in this game
why is this idea so interesting well at
first glance it looks like you're taking
a free pawn
seems great but upon further review you
are losing this rook
right and that's what makes this so
interesting this is just a straight
exchange sacrifice
by gregory opran in exchange for a
massive massive center
we see this happen after the move c4
bishop takes d5
c takes d5 and now black sort of has a
counter punch here
with the move knight e takes d4
highlighting the fact
that the bishop is underdefended and
this queen is overworked
knight d4 knight d4 played in the game
and then oprah
saves this bishop and we have a position
where white is simply down
a full exchange and has built
a pretty intimidating pretty big center
with some threats of pushing forward
even
even more a little bit later on now is
this the crazy material imbalance
that i'm talking about that got the game
into lecture obviously not but it's
still a very very interesting one
to take a look at right down just a
clean exchange but with positional
compensation for it uh
is pretty pretty nice knight f5 appears
on the board
and rook c2 activates gregory's final
piece right this night now
ready to jump in at a moment's notice
this bishop very active this bishop
lurking behind this d-pawn uh ready to
activate at any moment
and grigori just playing with
soul activity in exchange for his rook
versus uh bishop in exchange for the
rook yeah
queen b8 is cameron wheeler's choice in
this game desperately trying to stop the
move d6 from appearing on the board
now obviously black has a threat so we
see queen d3 by white
b5 tries to eject this knight but it
lands on the c5 square
rook a7 now to defend against any knight
d7 ideas
we see knight e4 uh gregory opran
rerouting a little bit here
and now black starts to get counter play
with the move b4
bishop b2 appears on the board and now
cameron tries to simplify with rook c7
gregory of course wants to keep uh these
rooks on the board
in general two rooks uh do not work that
well together
against one rook and one minor piece
black would much rather have
one rook versus one minor piece rather
than having the other set
of rooks on the board because these guys
often do the same job
in this case attacking the c file
whereas this guy
in combination with the bishop do very
very different jobs and so
they are a bit more useful together
rook d8 now played by black and we see
gregory go
knight g5 and his idea now is no longer
trying to push d6
black has done a very good job of making
this idea not very appealing
now he's going after the black king
which we see after the move a4
and the move e6 he's saying all rights
maybe i'll just try to checkmate you you
know exchange doesn't really matter
if you end up in checkmate bishop takes
b2 is cameron's idea perhaps the move f6
had to be tried
it looks very very ugly with g4 coming
and ideas of queen takes g6 and
knight f7 but it would keep this pawn
out of black's face instead though we
see bishop b2
of course white inserts e takes f7 check
king h8
and now rook takes b2 rook c3 appears on
the board
all of a sudden black is getting counter
play again we see queen e4
and i would just like to stop for a
moment all right let's let's all take a
moment here and pause
and examine this position all right so
white is still down the exchange
it is six pawns versus five
by my count so it's in exchange for the
pawn but what
exactly is going on here
well white has very much succeeded in
creating
uh some potential threats around
this black king but
in the meantime white is no longer
no longer without play sorry black is no
longer without play right he's gotten
this rook into the game there's some
threats around
white's king and very very importantly
given a few more turns
b3 a3 b2 b1 or b takes a2
or ab3 a3 a2 a1 these ideas are
coming very quickly for black and you
know in most cases
if you get a second queen you end up
winning the game
in most cases so
what exactly is going on here well it's
all just down to
tactical ideas in the game cayman tried
to immediately push with
b3 which turns out to allow
uh white some tactical opportunities
with the move
knight e6 and now of course there are
threats of
f8 coming threats um of
g4 as well i believe with the idea of
queen d4
and checkmate over here and
yeah this this position to be honest
with you is just a complete
and total mess um
yeah let's see what is actually going on
here what is the truth
well if you play a3 this might be the
most active idea
but now g4 a takes b2 g takes
b g takes f5 and you queen a moment too
slowly
as checkmate appears on the board this
is the idea why it's not even
considering taking this rick by the way
that white is just playing for checkmate
so with the tactics coming just in time
for gregory 96 would have been a nice
find
but that wasn't played in the game said
gregory captures back on b3
like a fool rook takes b3 now played
by um played by
or played by cameron wheeler and again
the tactics
start to be missed again understandably
turns out d6 is a winning idea here
um of course the idea is you're
interfering with this queen going for
the same checkmating ideas
so queen takes d6 to keep everything
under control and then the absolutely
insane move
queen takes a4 is winning the game for
gregory opran again
rook takes b2 queen e8 check and
checkmate
to follow takes queen and then queen
back to s7 queen h7
so what about a nice find but obviously
it's a rapid game you can only expect so
much
rook d2 was played instead
understandably
preserving the rook but now a3 comes on
the board
and sort of practically you know these
tactical ideas don't matter if they're
not found
and cameron says all right buddy i'm
making a queen
you either find the checkmate or you
don't uh in the game
oprah tries knight e6 setting up these
threats of g4 but it turns out d6 was
just a bit faster now especially with
the rook defending it
but 96 played in the game rook c8 played
in the game
as well um
and now g4 by gregory opran is the idea
trying to get onto this d4 square as
we've seen before
rook b4 is played queen f3 to dodge this
idea
but now rook b2 by cameron wheeler
and here again it turns out g takes f5
would have been winning
with the idea to follow of f takes g6
but this was missed understandably queen
f2
defends the rook from the threat of
capture we see takes takes queen b2
i'm zooming through this by the way this
part doesn't matter it doesn't matter at
all
it does matter but you know you can only
analyze so much of this game
and after rick takes d2 queen takes d2
queen b2
it suddenly looks as though all hope is
lost for gory oprah
right black has succeeded in completely
taking over this
uh diagonal there's no more tricky
tricks getting the queen out of here and
playing queen e5
uh and black is is queening shortly so
how does the result of this game make
any sense well it kind of doesn't
it kind of doesn't queen e1 played in
the game cameron wheeler very
quickly plays a2 why wouldn't you now g
takes f5 and cameron says all right
all right buddy you got me you you gave
it a good
fight i've got a second queen now what
are you gonna do
well your gory oprah captures captures
and captures and now believe it or not
chatroom
believe it or not there's one move
and only one move to win this position
only one move gives black a winning
position
so black to move chat what do you think
black to move black to move and win
i'll give you a few moments here but uh
i think to solve this this might be one
where you have to pause
at home to uh to find it because this is
a truly obscene position
so what do we think what can be done
here
all right the chat has some very
interesting ideas
um i'm not going to go through all the
legal moves here for black
but the key key idea is the move h4
um yeah uh
believe it or not h4 is the best move
here and perhaps the only move to win
black
has an advantage in other lines but h4
is the idea you keep the king
out of g3 and then white is sort of
helpless
eventually he's gonna have to play g7
we'll see takes takes and takes and now
this king just takes too long
to get back into the game rook c2 keeps
the king
locked out and this end game is going to
be
a victory for black
for example rook c3 king f2 king f7
and this one should be busted
i think i think it should be busted i
mean
it should be busted i think i think i
don't know anyways we never got this far
we never got this far because h4 wasn't
played
queen f6 was played and now this pawn is
attacked so bishop e4 comes on the board
and now h4
and you might be thinking okay no harm
no foul we got h4 in eventually
right but white to move
with at least equality at least equality
white to move and start playing for the
win
believe it or not it's true wait to move
and start
playing to win this chess game
so yes the key move here by the way
one one one rook one queen for a knight
and a bishop
okay that's the material imbalance we're
working with here just wanted to get
everybody on the same page
knight and bishop for rook and queen and
yes okay white has three pawns as well
but
don't worry about that knight in bishop
for rook and queen the idea
is king g2 and now we go king f3 and
then we go king g4
and then we go king h5 and then we go
king h6
what an idea what a conception by
gregory opran
queen b2 check played in the game now
king f3
queen c3 track now played in the game
and now king g4
and if you're black you might start
thinking hey wait a second
where's this guy going what's going on
here
everybody slow down but unfortunately
that moment of panic came a second too
late
for cameron wheeler it turns out there
were a few
ideas that would keep the balance here
queen f6
for example is a good idea for black and
the point now
is whenever this king lands on h6
g7 is made illegal and this is sort of
white's only idea so with the queen on
f6 i don't think black has too much to
fear
but after black's next and fatal mistake
and actually maybe there are some some
more ideas there for
for white unless i'm misremembering
yeah i don't know it doesn't matter
after black's next fatal mistake
queen g3 check believe it or not white
is completely winning in this position
with knight and bishop
for rook and queen the idea
as we've been discussing is king h5
rook b8 was played now king h6
and guess what rick f8
g7 check almost checkmate you have to
sacrifice this queen
and here gregory opran won the position
on time
and is completely winning in this end
game with the knight in the bishop
and the extra pawn against black's sole
remaining rook so this
might be the most ridiculous game of
chess i've ever seen in my entire
life it was definitely one that was
pretty incredible to see to see happen
hopefully you guys enjoyed this lecture
on some of the craziest material
imbalances
some of my favorite examples of it at
least throughout chess history
uh maybe i'll do a follow-up to this i
did have a few more games that i was
interested in going over that we didn't
quite get to uh because of time
so maybe next week tune in for more of
this let me know in the comments if i
missed
any uh of your favorite material
imbalances
and with that in mind if you're watching
live stay tuned the endgame class is
coming up right next i know i went a
little bit over time here but we will
still be having
that end game class um and that's it
thank you so much for joining i will see
you next time
you